let's talk about this first story
and this one is one of the creepiest and
strangest stories from Newsweek DARPA
denies funding Wuhan Institute of
virology amid alleged document League
they say Newsweek cannot confirm the
veracity of the DraStic group or the
existence of the project diffused
documents describe the groups as the
documents were provided anonymously
DARPA the U.S Advanced research projects
agency has denied funding research at
Wuhan of the one lab after a real after
a group released documents allegedly
detailing a coronavirus research
proposal they say drastic as a group of
activists who say they are working
towards solving the riddle of the
origins of SARS covid 2 and the virus
that is behind coven they say they were
given documents by anonymous source
which details something called project
diffuse according to what appeared to be
funding proposal excerpts published by
drastic project defuse aimed to reduce
the threat of bat-borne coronaviruses
through research and was headed by Peter
dashik president of the President of the
U.S U.S based research organization
ecohealth Alliance
it would have run between 2018 and 2022
drastic States the research proposal
would have involved Advanced and
dangerous Research into bet
coronaviruses in cooperation with the
Wuhan Institute of virology and other
facilities and said the research would
qualify as gain of function a process
can be used to make viruses more
dangerous however drastic to the
documents showed that DARPA rejected the
diffuse proposal in part because of gain
of function concerns specifically they
said something about we're not you know
we're not so sure about an aerosolized
vaccine the idea apparently was that
they were going to make some kind of air
Airborne aerosol that would take various
uh coronavirus particles they would
spray bats with so that bats would
develop some kind of immunity to it and
DARPA was like that sounds really
dangerous to do I'm with DARPA in this
one yeah I'm gonna go ahead and say I
agree with DARPA I'm not a big fan of
Matt let's not go spraying the vaccines
into the bat cave it makes me think of
fluoride in the water like just dumping
the medicine in the into the medium that
we is there in the water is it really
yeah I've heard not here oh okay good
now we have well water better it didn't
used to be but they started adding it I
think Floyd Michael yep not everybody
some some places uh don't but we have
well water so uh plus we have like a
nine stage filter or some ridiculous
number yeah so the article basically
goes on to say like in a function is
really really bad and all that stuff
they go on to then say in a statement of
Newsweek DARPA denied funding any
activity associated with equal Health
Alliance or the Wuhan Institute of
Urology a spokespa spokesman said in
accordance with the U.S federal
acquisition regulations we are not at
Liberty to divulge who may have or may
not have submitted a proposal in
response to any of the agency
solicitations further information
contained within bids is considered
proprietary and can only be released by
the bidder that being said DARPA has
never funded directly nor indirectly and
as a subcontractor any activity or
researcher associated with equal Health
Alliance or the Wuhan Institute of
virology why would Peter dashik he's the
guy who spearheaded the Lancet article
that said this is not from a lab
and now we hear that uh Cornelius
documents who's then later kicked off
the team by the way right and now Lance
is like coming out with a statement we
should investigate because it looks like
a lab leak and a serious and open debate
so this guy who's trying to get funding
from DARPA look there's NIH is one thing
with fauci you know being like we would
like to fund research in this area
because you're the National Institute of
Health or whatever it's another thing
when you go to DARPA I mean what what
could they possibly be trying to do
pitch to DARPA hey you want a weapon you
know it's amazing because you know I
know Alex was here on Monday but doesn't
this sound like something that you'd
hear on his show right yes he's like the
Chinese were working with a U.S firm and
they went to DARPA with their documents
and said we were going to be
aerosolizing the bat caves and it like
it just sounds it just I mean like it's
like he needs to be are you gonna go for
it he'd be like
you know I'm telling people that the
Chinese are coming to DARPA because the
U.S is working with China to to spray
the vaccine on the bats and and I'm just
like Alex slow down look they're gonna
go They're gonna go into the keys we're
gonna fact check this one and then I'm
like I really don't think the Chinese
went to a U.S defense research projects
to get like you know to get money to do
a lab to make Gain of function bio
weapons to spray bets and about Google
it and then I'd Google it and be like uh
from Newsweek uh uh Jamie pull it on
yeah virology was uh and and he called
the lines were seeking money from Darva
to weaponize you're like to weaponize
the aerosolization the human foreign
cleavage site of the okay so this uh
says that no what Alex checks out was
screaming about is entirely true so
where get the jar Jamie get the jar and
you put another coin Eco Health Alliance
lines went to DARPA is this a Chinese so
what if when you look at the actual
documents and I've gone through this and
I do actually dig through it on we talk
about it on the podcast today as well as
at humanevents.com where we go a little
deeper and we actually I was actually
reading the table of contents on this
because I've only been doing the podcast
for like a week but I'm trying to get
canceled as fast as possible so yeah so
I started I started reading the actual
table of contents in the leaked document
and I'm starting to go through it I'm
like I don't know if I can say this you
know and it was getting a little long
and we do we do a shorter version thing
there but they're talking about uh
infections experiments using entire
captive bat colonies uh they're visiting
the caves and the one that's really big
the introduction of human specific
cleavage sites so do you remember when
there was that big article that came out
by the former New York Times Reporter
where he was it was sort of like the
article that changed the conversation at
least for a lot of people out right all
of a sudden he was like all of a sudden
he was like hey we probably should talk
about the Lively because there's some
weird things well I actually went in and
read like all seven thousand words of
that because that's what I do
um and there's a huge section where he
said okay we're going to talk about
science now so for anybody who wants to
talk science this is that section
and one of the main things they were
talking about was this human Fern
cleavage site like that's that's where I
heard the phrase was in that article and
so I'm looking it up I'm talking to
people that um that I know who have been
in Pharma and r d Etc and one of whom
I'm sure is listening right now and
um the thing that was very interesting
to them was they said we don't know how
covid-19 could have evolved this so
specifically because it seems to be the
perfect addition to a Corona because
remember because the coronavirus is
there's not one coronavirus that's a
family name so that's like a Genus
that's like a family of a type of virus
and so for covid-19 they're just saying
that we haven't seen another coronavirus
with this specific
um feature to it right this this big
function to use a word and you know and
that's that's where gain of function
actually comes from that it doesn't have
this function
that it no one had gained this function
before none of them at least they'd
found and so the point of it was this
made the spike proteins essentially
because you always heard this early on
Spike proteins H2 receptors Spike
proteins ace2 receptors so our lungs
human lungs have these ace2 receptors
well with the Wuhan Institute of
virology was doing was they were
humanizing mice what were they doing
with the mice they were giving them the
ace to receptors in their lungs and so
the engineer the virus so to see if a
chimeric virus could essentially be be
able to be inserted to become
transgenically more pathologically
transmissible they were enhancing the
pathogenicity I had to practice that one
like three times in the mirror that's a
good word for doing that to work it out
and so it's really interesting that
again you know to everybody out there
that's kind of following this at once
more and not to like delve too into it
you just see these same terms coming up
again and again both at looking at the
science of what is covid-19 what makes
it so unique what makes it so uniquely
transmissible in human humans and then
also these Grant proposals that all are
associated with the Wuhan Institute of
horology I want to read this from the
telegraph they say DARPA refused to fund
the work saying quote it is clear that
the proposed project led by Peter dashek
could have put local communities at risk
and warned that the team had not
properly considered the dangers of
enhancing the virus gain of function
research or releasing a vaccine by air
wow so so DARPA was the the voice of
reason here yeah yeah DARPA is saying
hey guys let's just you know you know
Planet of the Apes yeah of course yeah
so so dashing the original of the Burton
the new one oh no I haven't seen that
one yet well the new one's all prequels
though right yeah yeah so in the new one
you know what it's about yeah it was
Caesar and all yeah yeah so they he
makes a virus keeps together strong yeah
makes a virus that enhances the
intelligence and functions of the chimps
but then it turns out that virus kills
humans so the humans are dying off for
the most part and the apes are
intelligent in building civilization and
I guess that's the prequel in the future
the humans are all gone and the apes are
all smart or whatever except for James
Franco but not anymore because he he
does die from the virus I'm pretty sure
okay
more immune and there's very few there
was like oh the guy from Zero Dark 30
isn't one of them so you have you have
DARPA basically being like if you guys
do a gain of function virus and then
spray covid particles on these animals
which then travel you know you might
destroy the planet so consider so we we
don't know according to these documents
if they they it doesn't say if they're
actually funded it says their proposals
um so maybe they went to fauci and found
right and so the point the point that
drastic makes and drastic has had a lot
of of legitimate scoops and research
that's come out in the they have an
excellent track record when it comes to
this
um the point that they make if you read
their summary is that you know we're not
saying we're not trying to pin this on
DARPA we're interested in what type of
research and what venues were they
looking at because as DARPA said in that
disclosure statement that hey this is
proprietary stuff we're not actually
allowed to share it because of the rules
Associated which makes sense right if
you're applying for a grant proposal but
you know if I you know if uh if uh
moderna shares it and you know sends me
a proposal and I share their Grant
Proposal with J and J because I you know
maybe my buddy works at J J and he said
he'd give me some money if I did
obviously you can think of proprietary
issues there but the question is what
Avenues of research were they looking
into what was going on and then
did they ever eventually get funding
from NIH or by the way did they get just
funding from the CCP for example to fund
these lines of research so again we only
have so far uh insight into what has
been published from the Wuhan Institute
and we have better insight into what we
funded we being the US government the US
Nation but we don't really know there's
a whole Black Box surrounding that
entire thing and it seems like every
time we get another leak every time we
get more documents every time we dig up
one of these statements that was made
right in real time when you go look at
this I pulled up that
New York Times article from 2017 that
says well it looks like we're going to
be funding gain of function research now
which could produce more lethal viruses
right um you know New York Times I'm
done playing games look the hunter the
laptop store the hunter Biden laptop
story comes out and immediately you get
people on the right of course willing to
start digging into it trying to fact
check it verify a lot of the stuff and
it was almost immediately verified in a
bunch of ways notably Tony bobulinski
who is like a confidant being like yeah
these emails are real and it takes what
a year for the mainstream media to go oh
they're real by the way and then people
go oh I still remember sitting there and
it was um you know uh you know Bannon
gives us the hard drive and that was
with Raheem and we we're just sitting
out at Morton's on the Terrace and he
starts he's like oh look at this video
I'm like God don't show me that we're in
public you know but I'm like that's
definitely 100 Biden so no question
about that I'm not trying to rehash all
of that because right I see the
snowstorm I'm like we knew this right
yeah we we knew the story was bunk we
knew Russia gate at a certain point was
bank I was willing to entertain gate and
then eventually I was just like these
people have lost their minds it was
getting crazier and crazier Ukraine gate
was completely bunk it's all been bunked
the media's lied about about way too
much but Tim here's the thing is I was
going on every single day publicly
during this period so the eight was
essentially eight weeks before the
election and I was I was going I said
Jake Tapper Maggie Haberman actually got
into it on Twitter with Mark Cuban a
little bit over this because he actually
responded I said if you guys want to
come and get a copy of this thing I will
let you sit down I will give you full
access to it I'll let you make a copy of
it I'll let you take it off with you you
can send it to like I would like to know
personally as well but I also understand
that we live in this environment where
there's sort of like the Independent
Media and then there's like the accepted
formal mainstream media right and so I
understand that unless this hard drive
passes through that you know that
barrier that that you know impermeable
most of the time barrier uh into quote
unquote accepted media channels as
opposed to like podcast independent
media that this aren't going to happen
so I said guys come on to get a copy of
it I'm more than happy I'm just saying
I'm done playing games when it comes to
lab leak we've got so much evidence
pointing in the direction to
research being funded at the Wuhan lab
that was specifically working on gain of
function coronaviruses to infect the
lungs and now we have a coronavirus from
Wuhan that infects the lungs bro I'm
done I'm not playing these stupid games
anymore the people understand what
happened at the very least it was a lab
leak thanks for checking out this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast if you want
to see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time